and then she becomes quite dark and
loses her humanity completely
angelina jolie intimidating angelina as
maleficent
downright unnerving well well
but these maleficent bloopers and
behind-the-scenes moments
might just change your mind the truth is
the maleficent cast are all one
laid-back family who have selfie
sessions on set
and angelina she spent her time filming
having a prank battle with charltoe
copley
what a turn of offense i'm pretty good
at ping pong
yeah she's just easy i'm like there's no
doubt that angelina jolie takes her
craft
very seriously if she didn't we wouldn't
have her iconic movies like the tourist
and by the sea
but that doesn't mean she can't have fun
while acting
some of her best behind the scenes
moments on the set of maleficent have
her completely breaking character
the dark trey began with her
showing us she may be one of hollywood's
best but she doesn't take herself too
seriously we're still not sure if it's
endearing or downright creepy to see her
dressed as maleficent with a constant
smile on her face
unlike angelina it's not so hard to
believe that behind the scenes elle
fanning spent a lot of her time laughing
and being silly just like her character
aurora l fanning is like a ball of
sunshine
her energy definitely came across in the
movie and now we're seeing it come to
life
behind the scenes as well
[Music]
check out some of her most adorable
moments it's safe to say the world would
be a better place if we were all as
free-spirited as
l i i think i'm a pretty honest person
um we may have got to see another side
of angelina through her bloopers
but no matter how sweet it looked to us
the kids on set were absolutely
terrified of the maleficent getup
so terrified they had to have angelina's
daughter vivian play the younger version
of aurora
she was the only child who didn't burst
into tears when she spoke to them
even brad pitt came in to support look
at how cute it was to watch angelina
pretend like it was actually playtime
for her daughter
instead of work we made it fun so we all
had fun together
smooth filming isn't always up to the
cast and crew props are a big part of
movie sets and when one of them isn't
functioning properly
things can get a little complicated
maleficent
wasn't short on prop mishaps l literally
broke a fake window
okay and that happened
but at least these bloopers were able to
make these moments look hilarious
instead of time consuming they all took
it in stride
we have on set it's it's like a joyous
feeling
together who doesn't love a good dance
session especially when they're
random well it looks like the maleficent
cast and crew couldn't say no to
occasionally breaking it down while we
all tend to have these impromptu dance
parties in our bedrooms
these actors are having fun together in
between takes
excuse us as we try not to be jealous of
everyone on set getting to have a jam
session with angelina and
elle you do have to admit these dance
parties are not that unwarranted
they should be celebrating they had two
huge boxed office successes
everyone needs a good selfie session
every once in a while even hollywood
actors
the b-roll caught the cast especially
elle and angelina
having a selfie session in their
costumes between takes they probably
couldn't get over how bizarre it looked
to see their characters using those
snapchat filters
we don't blame them these bonding
moments just go to show how tight-knit
this cast was
and how much fun they had filming
because of it so funny with them in the
modern world that's
hilarious sam riley's character diaval
may be tortured dark and mysterious but
in real life
he's the life of the party you know
those people who were the class clowns
in grade school
we're betting he was definitely one of
them he spent
so much time behind the scenes making
funny faces breaking character
and overall getting people to loosen up
and have fun just take a look at his
best moments
we're not gonna lie we kind of want to
be his best friend
you know it's not my usual you know
bread and butter the
indie films queen ingress cat wasn't so
well behaved behind the scenes
guess you could say the maleficent set
had a little bit of a furry
situation although the kitty did a
fantastic job on screen
the crew had to deal with moments where
it would scurry in front of the camera
when it wasn't supposed to
and one crew member even had to pry the
cat off the tablecloth
in the middle of filming queen ingress
dinner scene i think it comes
from not having a background of formal
training
you know in the beginning these next
bloopers are pretty self-explanatory
even the best actors forget their lines
sometimes and that's totally okay
they just laugh it off and try again is
it just us or is there some
metaphorical message about never giving
up behind this
either way it's hilarious to watch don't
get married so quickly
elle fanning and bretton thwaites
brought to life one of the most iconic
disney couples aurora and prince philip
we're still not over how magical their
wedding was but what might be even more
magical
is to watch the two actors chemistry
even off-screen
there's no denying that these two
completely got along and connected
so well without their bond and silly
behind the scenes moments
we probably wouldn't have gotten the
same chemistry between the two in the
film's final cut
by now we've all seen the video of
angelina transforming into maleficent
the two and a half hour process included
prosthetics for her cheekbones and a
very
very heavy headpiece she spoke out about
how it wasn't really the makeup that
bothered her
but the horns they made her so tall that
she would knock or get caught on things
all the time
they even caught it in the bloopers we
can only imagine how many other times
that happened to her
because angie does wear these for about
14 hours a day
elle fanning has her own favorite moment
from filming maleficent and it was
during a scene that they only had
one take to film remember when she was
having a mud fight with the creatures in
the woods
well because her dress couldn't be
washed she only had one shot
this one green dress and we only had
like one take
to do it in and you know it was very
specific what made it more hilarious was
that the creatures were added in later
on
so she was really fighting tennis balls
and crew members
throwing mud that was kind of crazy to
to you know see all those that things
going on we talked earlier about how
angelina jolie's career in hollywood has
been
absolutely phenomenal but what might be
more admirable
is how she uses her knowledge to help
everyone on set
there are a few b-roll moments where we
can see her really getting into her
element and sharing her expertise with
the cast
and even the crew honestly it's kind of
inspirational
elle also gushed about another moment
during the filming of maleficent that
she'll never forget
the wedding same l same
she was most excited about getting to
wear the beautiful wedding dress
or as she likes to call it this is the
sleeping beauty dress
i never wanted to take it off all in all
it was a dream come true moment for her
and you can definitely
see how amazed she was in the behind the
scenes footage just look at her
maleficent is the story of sleeping
beauty
but you get to know a lot more this may
be the most shocking behind the scenes
moment of them all
angelina spent her time on set engrossed
in an
ongoing prank battle with charlton
copley according to sam
charlton started it but angelina
definitely won
we haven't gotten any official footage
from any of the pranks
maleficent i've come to warn you but if
we take a listen to charlton they'll
tell you all you need to know
it was it was a constant battle between
different ways of kind of one-upping
each other
suddenly pricking our finger on a
spindle and being cursed doesn't sound
like the worst thing in the world if it
meant we could spend time with this cast
with someone as hilarious as sam riley
on set or as inspirational as angelina
jolie
we totally get why elle fanning is
constantly gushing about her co-stars
what was your favorite behind the scenes
[Music]
moment